um muhammad makes a living selling
charcoal
a single taxi fare in syria's capital
damascus costs the same as her daily
income
so she carries out her errands across
the city on foot
andrew and padmet's baccalaureate i have
a daughter working towards her high
school certificate one of the main
reasons she failed her class was because
of transport she registered at a school
she would walk if she couldn't catch
public transportation if she couldn't
find any she would need a taxi which i
cannot afford
she says people in the city have stopped
socializing because of the spiraling
fuel costs
taxi and mini bus drivers in syria
struggled to make a living during a
decade of conflict
and now with the surge in energy prices
around the world it's becoming tougher
two weeks ago authorities more than
doubled the cost of subsidized petrol
it's stressful i have high blood
pressure and i've had two strokes but i
want to live i don't want to beg it's
difficult for me to beg
even though beggars make more money
nowadays begging is more profitable than
the minibus
in the eleven years since the war in
syria began its local currency has
collapsed to barely one percent of its
pre-war value
and that's leaving little hope
for its people
julian wolfe al jazeera